so President Trump holds a big
immigration meeting with Democrats Steve
Bannon is out at Breitbart news and
apparently back to bagging groceries
where he belongs and it turns out that
President Obama designed his own library
it does not look good I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so a lot to get to today obviously
there's a lot of breaking news on
immigration including a judicial ruling
that is just absurd also Steve Bannon is
out at Breitbart and as you may have
noticed this does not displease me Plus
as I have to show the pictures of the
Obama Presidential Library because they
truly are astonishingly awful I mean
it's like the guy took a Chinese takeout
food box unwrapped it and then decided
to model his library on it
that's basically what it looks like
Malthus is nodding because he knows this
is true before we get to any of that we
are first going to say thank you to my
sponsors over at Birch gold so Birch
gold is the place that you need to go if
you're interested in hedging your
financial bets if you look at the stock
market right now it's doing great it's a
so but over 25,000 but there may be a
correction sometime in the near future
if you look at the real estate market
it's up to but that may be a bubble one
of the ways that you can protect against
government inflation one of the ways
that you can protect against economic
uncertainty is with precious metals and
that's why you need to go and talk to my
friends over at Birch gold group Birch
gold group has a long-standing track
record of continued success thousands of
satisfied clients countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau contact Birch gold group
right now to request a free information
kit on physical precious metals it's a
comprehensive 16 page kit and it reveals
how gold and silver can protect your
savings and how you can legally move
your IRA or 401k out of stocks and bonds
and into a precious metals IRA ask all
your questions and get all of them
answered and then when ready to invest
talk to birchgold.com / Ben again that
is birchgold.com / Ben go check it out
right now use the slash Ben so that they
know that we sent you okay so well I'm
desperate to begin with President
Obama's a presidential library because
the pictures are just so astonishing
you're gonna have to wait for that first
we're gonna start with President Trump
having his big immigration meeting at
the White House so there were two
purposes for this immigration being
purpose number one is to push back on
the Michael Wolf fire and fury
narratives that narrative which we
talked about at length yesterday suggest
that Trump is just a crazy person Trump
is a nutjob a child and a man body a
sort of a kook who's escaped from the
asylum and is now running amuck through
the White House destroying everything
and so Trump wanted to hold this
bipartisan meeting to show no you know
I'm gonna have a basically normal
meeting and we'll have a bunch of
Democrats to the White House and we'll
talk and nobody'll get
in the head with a frying pan it'll
totally be fine and in that he succeeded
he was fine
when it came to policy however things
were not quite so glowing president gave
a bunch of mixed signals about what he
would be willing to sign or what he
would not be willing to sign in terms of
data now to review if you recall back in
26 two back in 2012 Barack Obama passed
into law sort of through executive order
the executive amnesty this was a
deferred action for childhood arrivals
program it suggested that anyone between
the ages of 16 and 30 at the time that
he signed this into law that those
people would be able to stay if they
were brought into the country as
children that had been there for a
certain amount of time and that being
the case all those people would
eventually be legal citizens of the
United States was sort of the unspoken
promise that Obama was making so Trump
comes into office and several months
into his term he decides that he is
going to overturn daca but at the time
he says daca no longer applies but if
Congress doesn't pass some version of
daca to keep the so-called dreamers in
the United States then come March
maybe I'll just reinstate it which is a
weird statement to make because the
whole reason for striking down daca in
the first place was based on
constitutional grounds he said it's
unconstitutional for the President of
the United States to simply say that a
bunch of people are now going to get
green cards to stay in the United States
or papers that suggest that they can be
here legally without the approval of
Congress so it would be weird to reverse
himself and then say well you know what
I decided the constitutional question
doesn't matter now I want this policy
back in place and therefore it will be
back in place that would be a weird
argument for Trump to make so yesterday
Trump is at the White House and he leads
off with his actual proposal his actual
proposal is that he will sign into law
and enshrinement of daca right basically
legalizing the presence of the so-called
dreamers maybe giving them a pathway to
citizenship maybe not maybe allowing
them to stay in the country permanently
without the ability to vote for example
it's not clear what exactly he's talking
about here but he says there won't be
any staying in the country for the
dreamers unless I get the funding for my
border wall now this is a fairly
unremarkable position that Republicans
have been taking there's some hardliners
like Ann Coulter who have been
suggesting that under no circumstances
should Trump reinstate daca instead he
should just push for independent funding
of the border wall and said he should
just push for an end to chain migration
chain migration is the process by which
you come here you drop a baby and the
baby's a citizen and now the baby brings
you in as the parent
as a citizen and it's chain migration
you bring in your entire family in fact
the the last terrorist attack that
occurred in New York City was by
somebody who'd been brought in
essentially through chain migration
started off as a person who got in
through the visa lottery that person
brought their family over through chain
migration Trump wants to end chain
migration as well he should chain
migration is stupid the idea that you
get to bring your entire family over
just because you're here how about we
determine whether you bringing your
family over is good for the United
States rather than just simply assuming
it especially when you're talking not
about immediate family or talking about
cousins and uncles and aunts and
grandmothers and all the rest in any
case the the Ann Coulter's say no daca
at all now that is what I would prefer
to I would prefer a system where we look
at all of these people on a one-to-one
basis I've said this a thousand times
where we look at these folks and a
one-to-one level we decide whether they
ought to stand whether they ought to go
and then they go in the back of the line
they can stay here while they're waiting
for their actual papers but they have to
go to the back of the line because it's
not fair to privilege them over people
who have been waiting diligently in line
for years to get their green card and
get their citizenship but President
Trump thinks differently he thinks that
data has to stay the reason for that is
he doesn't want the ugly pictures of ice
coming in and deporting people just
ripping children out of their mother's
arms and then putting them on a plane to
El Salvador and this is not something
that Trump really wants to do or the
opposite getting rid of that taking
mothers and the baby was born here so
the baby is a citizen taking the mothers
and deporting the mothers and leaving
the babies here
Trump doesn't want any of those pictures
so he says we want to do daca we want to
akka done but we're also gonna get my
priorities done so in order for
Democrats to sign off on this
Democrats want what is called a clean
daca bill whenever they say clean clean
just means without any riders so what
they want is daca rien shrined without
any wall funding without any curbs on
chain migration without any curbs on the
diversity Visa Lottery Trump would like
if DAC is gonna get done all of the
above he wants an end to chin migration
he wants curbs on the diversity visa
lottery wants it done away with
he wants his funding for the border wall
and that's what he said yesterday and by
the way as I said a couple of days ago
that deal was not a bad deal right it's
not it's not a terrible deal right if if
he ends up basically retaining status
quo with regard to the dreamers who by
the way we're never really gonna be
deported if he ends up retaining status
quo but getting all of his policy
priorities that's a win for the
president he knows it and that's why
that was what his position
was yesterday here's what he said love
not to build the wall but you need the
wall and I will tell you this the ice
officers and the Border Patrol agents I
had them just recently open for you they
say if you don't have the wall you know
in certain areas obviously that aren't
protected by nature if you don't have
the wall you cannot have security just
can't have it it doesn't work no I think
a plea dockable to me is a dr. bill but
we take care of the 800,000 people
they're actually not necessarily young
people everyone talks about young you
know they could be 40 years old 41 years
old but they're also 16 years old but I
think to me a clean bill is a bill of
Dokka we take care of them and we also
take care of security okay so the reason
that he's reship ting at the end there
is for a reason that I will show you in
just a moment because the fact is that
President Trump doesn't know what clean
bill means and so now he's
recapitulating what clean bill means now
clean bill is supposed to mean including
security which is not what clean bill
means typically there are a lot of mixed
messages in this press conference now
does he look like he is in control yes
and that's what he wants it right so
this is this gives the lie to the idea
that Trump doesn't know what he's doing
or that he has no capacity to function
in this office this is the problem with
Democrats setting the bar so low when
you suggest that somebody legitimately
does not have the IQ points to function
in a given job and then the person seems
to be functional then it is a visual
rebuke to all of the lines that have
been used by Democrats over the past
year a couple of years about Trump being
so crazy that he can't be allowed
anywhere near the Oval Office
here is a here's Trump continuum but the
bigger story I think for conservatives
is the mixed messages so Trump for
example dropped a full on Jeb Bush line
he suggested that he wanted a bill of
love I remember when Jeb Bush said that
trying to legalize the illegal
immigrants was an act of love and he was
ripped up and down for the privilege
right one of the people ripping him was
Donald Trump how dare you say act of
love and Jeb's sort of retreated into
the corner well Donald Trump did exactly
the same thing yesterday he talked about
how he wanted a bill of love now we're
going to have a
bill of love first of all I don't think
that we should have Bills of love I
think we should have Bill's a good
policy just as a general rule I'll show
you what Trump said in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Enzo chinos so you want
to look your best right you have a big
business meeting coming up or you have a
wedding coming up or you have a big date
coming up and you want to look at
stylish as you possibly can well that's
where Enzo Chino comes in indochina
makes you a made-to-measure suit it fits
better compared to a generic
off-the-rack suit it is made from
scratch they're the largest custom
apparel company they make suits and
shirts to your exact measurements for a
great fit here's how it works you pick
your fabric you choose your
customizations you submit your
measurements you place your order and
you wait for her to arrive and three
weeks or less or you can go into one of
their headquarters in places like Los
Angeles I went into their headquarters
in in Beverly Hills and it was a really
fun experience actually got to look at
all the different modifications and the
tailor works with you to figure out
exactly how you want it to look it all
looks great my favorite suit that I own
is actually a blue / gray a light blue /
gray three-piece suit with a vest it is
very stylish it is very colorful and it
definitely draws eyeballs not just
because I'm a deeply handsome human
being but also because the suit is just
great-looking you can shop online at
endo Chino comm or visit any of their
showrooms across North America and right
now my listeners get any premium Indo
Chino suit for just 359 bucks at ENSO
Chino comm when you enter Shapiro at
checkout that's 359 bucks Indo chinos
combo you enter Shapiro at checkout
that's 50% off the regular price for a
premium made-to-measure suit again
shipping is free Indo Chino kaam promo
code Shapiro any premium suit 359
dollars plus free shipping so cheaper
than off the rack and better than off
the rack fits better looks better has
all the modifications you want feel like
you're James Bond right you've got that
you've got the the actual you know
tailored suit to match your coolness
that's what endo Chino is for again it's
called I and do CH Ino comm endo Chino
calm and use promo code Shapiro a check
out for that special deal okay so from
says that he wants a bill of love so
here is him explaining what he wants
from deca and again you'll see that the
message is moving around a fair bit here
we have a lot of good people in this
room a lot of people that have a great
spirit for taking care of people we
represent we all represent I feel having
the Democrats in with us is absolutely
because this should be a bipartisan bill
there should be a bill of love truly
should be a bill of love and we can do
that the bill of love and Jeb Bush
somewhere just as crying and crying
because if only he had been Donald Trump
and said Bill of love everything would
have been fine but he said act of love
and from Brooke through up and down for
so here is where the confusion sets in
so it looks like Trump has a relatively
clear position so far right we're gonna
get daca but we're also gonna get border
wall funding and we're also going to get
the end of chain migration and we're
also going to get the end of the
diversity Visa Lottery again is it would
I prefer that he not do daca and get all
of those things sure if you're gonna
make a trade though that's not a bad
trade right that's about as good a trade
as you're going to get I was advising a
couple of Republican senators last night
on this and I was saying push as hard as
you can the reason I was saying push as
hard as you can is because Trump
actually is not gonna take a leadership
role the great lie of the last campaign
is that Trump was gonna take a
leadership role when it came to actual
policy prescriptions such as on
immigration that he was gonna be the
great leader here he is not and he made
that pretty clear yesterday so here is
Trump debating with Democrats and you
will see that Trump legitimately does
not actually know what he's talking
about when it comes to the terminology
on jacta he actually has to be corrected
by representative Kevin McCarthy the
House Majority Whip on his position
because for a moment here he actually
signals support for the Democratic
position that daca should be passed
without any sort of strings attached to
here as Diane Feinstein saying something
and then her being absolutely stunned
when Trump agrees with her with the
commitment that we go into a
comprehensive keep pausing for one
second okay before we get to Trump's
answer what she's saying
just to clarify is that she wants
deferred action for childhood arrivals
Obama's executive amnesty made law now
and then afterward we'll negotiate about
diversity visa programs and we'll
negotiate about curbing chain migration
here's the problem if Trump were to do
that he loses all leverage the only
leverage she has to get Democrats to
vote for this thing is that they want
akka and if they won't attack him maybe
they'll give him some of the things he
wants if he gives them what they want
you think they're gonna stick around for
a discussion about comprehensive
immigration reform
are you kidding of course they're not
going to of course they'll sink any
possibility of curbing some of the more
popular methods of illegal immigration
so that's what she's saying to him she's
saying let's do what I want and then
later later we'll do what you want and
she's doing the wimpy from from the
Archie comics they give me a give me a
hamburger now I'll give you the five
bucks later that's basically what you're
saying and then she's shocked because
Trump doesn't know what she's saying and
so he agrees with her as what happens
right here
Kennedy's here I think that's basically
what dick is said we're gonna come out
with daca we're gonna do daca and then
we can start immediately on the Phase
two which would be comprehensive I think
a lot of people would like to see them
but I think we have to do it when we
talk about just daca we don't want to be
back here two years later you have to
have security as the secretary would
tell you I think that's what you say
okay easy Kevin McCarthy steps in
there's a mr. president I knew you're
totally wrong about this so this is the
problem with the idea that Trump is
going to lead the way on this because
Trump legitimately doesn't know what
he's talking about and so he has to have
Kevin McCarthy Kevin McCarthy is no hawk
on immigration by the way hey Kevin
McCarthy is from California he is not an
immigration hawk and he has to step in
and inform the president this is not how
negotiations work and then Trump
basically starts giving away the store
so this is the problem with with the
meeting you know mr. president just just
please pipe down let Congress do its
work sign what comes across your desk
you can hear when Trump starts to
negotiate his opening negotiation for
position for a guy who's supposed to be
this master negotiator his opening
negotiation position is let me give you
everything you want that was also his
opening negotiation position if you
recall on the budget where he told the
Democrats here have everything you want
and he stunned Paul Ryan and he's
stunned Mitch McConnell and both of them
walked out of trumps office going what
the hell just happened that's what
happened yesterday - on immigration
briefly now Trump I think is going to
back down now my Congress do its work
but you can see why Republicans are a
little bit discomforted with the idea
that captain immigration hawk over here
is giving away the entire store right
halfway through this meeting Trump
actually says we don't need a wall
that's what he campaigned on guys right
build the wall build the wall and then
he says if the White House build the
fence in parts of the border that aren't
covered by water or mountains which
doesn't have quite the same ring to it
here's the president I had to think
meeting with
ice last week I had a big meeting with
the Border Patrol agents last week
nobody knows it better than them as an
example of the wall they say sir we
desperately need the wall and we don't
need a 2,000 mile whoa we don't need a
wall where you have rivers and mountains
and everything else protecting but we do
need a wall for a fairly good portion
okay so this is a change from what he
said during the campaign because people
were saying to him exactly this and
you're saying no no no no it's cuz
you're a wimp it's cuz you're a wimp
that you don't want to build a wall
along the entirety of the border
hey now he's saying what everybody else
was saying which is you can have a wall
in places you don't have to have a wall
in places and then it gets worse then he
says listen you guys let's be real about
this I'll sign anything I mean he really
says this he said like he actually this
came out of his mouth so that as I say
the meeting was good for him on an image
level because it made him look as though
he actually wants to deal and he can
speak full sentences and he's capable of
carrying on a conversation and he's
capable of listening to McCarthy
McCarthy says mr. president whoa there
hold your horses but watch trump's
saying listen you send me something not
gonna be no what comes across my desk
I'll sign it a this is an astounding
again an astonishing negotiation
position when this group comes back
hopefully with an agreement this group
and others from the Senate from the
house comes back with an agreement I'm
signing it I mean I will be signing
again I'm not going to say oh gee I want
this round what that I'll be signing it
because I have a lot of confidence in
the people in this room that you're
gonna come up with something really good
oh gee I'm not gonna sign this room not
gonna sign that it's called the veto
power right if you're not threatened to
use the veto pen what in the world are
you doing in this office like at a
certain point you are gonna have to
threaten to use the veto pen now if all
of trumps most you know most ardent
supporters the people who are the in
Trump we trust Dan Coulter types are
looking at this they're going crazy and
Ann Coulter was to her credit going
insane yesterday right Ann Coulter was
losing her mind over this press
conference basically saying that it is a
full-on disaster right she said she's
tweeted out this morning quote if Trump
was FDR we have nothing to fear but fear
itself but nothing against fear fear is
good too believe me
if Trump was JFK asking out what your
country can do for you unless you want
to then ask away
if Trump was Reagan mr. Gorbachev tear
down this wall or leave it up your call
I'm good either way
if Trump was Paul
there's all from Ann Coulter she wrote a
book called in Trump we trust right now
God in Trump well apparently that Trump
has been that Trust has been betrayed
according to Colton she says appalled if
Trump was Paul Revere at the British who
are some of my best friends they're
coming and going and it's all very
exciting
if Trump was Churchill we shall fight on
the beaches or if we have a world-class
picnic there depends entirely on the
weather so she is just ripping him up
and down suggesting that he has
completely failed his own base that you
know she is she called the lowest day of
his presidency she says as he continues
the utility as he considers the utility
of walls and promises Trump should
consider that never Trump was toothless
but former Trump will bite right she's
going on and on here about about Trump's
big big statement yesterday Mickey cow
said Democrats and Republicans struck
notes of cautious optimism after the
meeting with both sides seeming to agree
that the wall and border security are
interchangeable terms sellouts same
sellout strategy so there are a lot of
people who are very very critical of
Trump here from his right and Trump you
know should notice that now in reality
is Trump gonna be the one who's defining
policy he's not gonna be the one
defining policy and and Trump basically
just throws things out there let's be
frank about this anytime Trump talks
he's throwing crap against the wall
that's just his his strategy typically
he's throwing crap against the wall so
yesterday in the middle of the meeting
he just throws out there what if we
brought back two earmarks so if you
recall a few years ago Congress banned
earmarks earmarks in the process by
which you add pork to bills the the case
in favor of earmarks is that you can't
get anything done without them because
you have to pay off all the members of
Congress to vote for your bill that's
the case in favor of earmarks is what
they call pork barrel rolling that
basically you hand somebody pork and
then they vote for your bill that was
banned because people said why are we
wasting all this money on the Robert
Byrd Memorial Highway in West Virginia
in order to pass a defense bill that
makes no sense Trump says why don't we
bring back the earmarks and you can see
members of Congress like wait what did
he just say the other Republicans are
saying wait wait you came here to drain
the swamp and they're talking about
earmarks really the old earmark system
how there was a great friendliness when
you had here marks but of course they
had other problems with the earmarks but
maybe all of you should start thinking
about going back to a form of earmarks
you should do it
and I'm there with you because this
system really lends itself to not
getting along okay so much swamp
training so much swamp raining bring
back the air max my goodness
so Trump says a lot of stuff but here's
the point in the end this is gonna be
negotiated by Congress and in just a
second I'm gonna explain to you what
exactly Congress is saying about this
because Congress has a Congress you know
is is obviously Republicans and
Democrats have very different visions of
this one of the things that's been kind
of hysterical and funny about all of
this is the fact that the media were
sort of taken aback by Trump speaking in
full sentences like a human and so they
started saying well everyone agrees on
this they don't write first of all I
think it is important to point out that
Jeff Flake is not wrong the senator from
Arizona when he says that he was
surprised it Trump's flexibility at the
meeting I think everyone was on the
right on the left because this is the
thing Trump doesn't actually have a lot
of policy beliefs this is one of the
dangers in Republicans losing Congress
for all of the Republicans you say Trump
is the party Trump is the entire party
if Trump loses Congress if the Democrats
take over the house and if they take
over the Senate I'm gonna talk about the
Senate in a few minutes here because Joe
Arpaio announced his candidacy for
Senate in Arizona which is a beautiful
way for Republicans to lose another
Senate seat in a red / purple state like
Arizona but Jeff Flake he says I'm
surprised at Trump's flexibility the
reason that's a problem is because if
Democrats take Congress they will start
passing bills do you think that Trump's
gonna sit there with a veto pen this is
a guy who's very angry well I would say
angry very anxious not to use the veto
pen he doesn't what he wants to get
things done he likes having his name on
things and it doesn't matter if it's
democrat bill I think or a Republican
bill he's not somebody who's gonna go to
war with Democrats when they run the
Congress it's easy for them to go to war
him to go to war with them when they're
in the minority it's a lot harder when
they're passing bills and putting them
on his desk and they because here's Jeff
Flake saying that he was surprised at
Trump's flexibility frankly I went in
with pretty low expectations you don't
put 22 people around the table and
expect to really negotiate and we're at
a point now where we really need to
negotiate but I was surprised at you
know what
was left at the president's flexibility
on the matter and that he actually went
in and explained what he meant by the
wall and border security and that's
helpful it really is me so there there
are a couple different positions inside
the Republican caucus the position
that's hardline says we're gonna get all
the things that Trump originally said he
wanted the position that soft line says
we'll have border security but no wall
will add a few ice agents will maybe
curb the diversity Visa Lottery but
we're not gonna make any big changes
that's how it's gonna get hashed out
okay just just so you know that's how
it's gonna get hashed out it's gonna be
hashed out how what can you get to 51
with and it may be something we can
maybe something very weak because there
are a lot of weak Republicans in the
Senate martha mcsalley who's currently
running for she announced yesterday
she's a House member that she's gonna be
running for the Senate seat in Arizona
to fill Jeff Flake seat actually she
says listen we're not gonna give them
daca in return for nothing we're gonna
have to get something out of this we've
been working on this tirelessly for the
last four months together and we expect
to be dropping it as early as tomorrow
and we believe again if you look at on
the one side you see the Democrats are
asking for the DREAM Act are nothing
that's a non-starter I think most
Republicans are willing to do have a
conversation about daca recipients but
we've got to make sure that we secure a
border and that we don't end up in a
situation where we have 800,000 more
daca recipients in one to five years
from now so these are very reasonable
requests that are going to be in our
bill that are dressing public safety
issues like sanctuary cities strong
border security also the chain migration
Visa Lottery and some tweaks to asylum
reform unaccompanied minor form those
types of things are going to be in our
bill and and this is again us showing
that we're willing to be reasonable and
address this issue but we've got to
address the root causes as to why we
have this issue in the first place okay
this is why we need people like mcsalley
actually there this is why it's
important the Republicans not lose seats
and this is why this story about our pie
o
running for Senate in Arizona mcsalley
could be your senator she has voted 100%
of the time of Trump not 95% 99% 100% of
the time she's voted with Trump now I
want to make something clear yesterday I
was wrong and I want to apologize to
Kelly Ward I had suggested that she
believes in chemtrails or some such
nonsense that was a rumor those put out
by the McConnell camp it is not true
if she was asked about it at some
townhall and she sort of gave credence
to the question mildly but that's not
the case
Kelly Ward has some other problems with
her candidacy that is not one of them
but our piyo jumping into the race in
Arizona makes it likely that Republicans
lose this seat okay right now our piyo
jumped in and the polls are now showing
that our piyo is running neck and neck
with mcsalley and ward so before Ward
was defeating what was defeating
mcsalley by some huge number she was who
she was up on mcsalley by 20% or
something now it's mcsalley at 31%
Arpaio at 29% ward at 25%
mix Ali's not a moderate timox Ali has
pushed a lot of legislation with
Democratic co-sponsors but none of it
has been particularly left for example
and she's very pro-life again she's
voted 96% of the time within a
Republican Party and a hundred percent
of the time of President Trump her
drawback in the primaries is that she
was not an ardent supporter of Trump in
the 2016 election she's a retired Air
Force colonel who recently joined the
House in 2015 she's hawkish on foreign
policy
so Arpaio by contrast is just toxic
okay he's 85 years old who's pardoned by
President Trump who's about to go to
prison for ignoring a korver to stop
racially profiling even if you think
that sentence was unjust there are a lot
of other problems with our pyo's
candidacy his office
the the maricopa county sheriff's office
failed to investigate hundreds of sex
crimes including child molestations they
had journalists arrested and then they
had to pay out millions of dollars in
reparations to those journalists he
tried to charge political opponents
apparently his department at one point
burned down a house and searched for
illegal weapons that weren't found and
then and killed the dog in the process
and then apparently charged the charge
of the owner of the home with traffic
violations to try and justify it in in
backwards fashion they wasted hundreds
of millions of dollars in various ways
there's a reason that our piyo during
the last election cycle in 2016 actually
lost his sheriff's race by something
like ten points in the same election
where Trump won the state by 3 and also
Arpaio happens to be a birther guys
there are a lot of drawbacks to Joe
Arpaio
he's currently running neck-and-neck
with Kelly Ward and martha mcsalley
the big problem here the biggest problem
here is that when you look at Ward Ward
who has suggested that McCain and John
McCain was quote-unquote directly
responsible for the rise of Isis and
suggested that after Cain was diagnosed
with cancer he should have stepped down
and
favor she does support Trump she was
very supportive of Trump she was a Steve
Bannon project until his career imploded
which we'll talk about in a few minutes
she ran against McCain in primary in
2016 as she lost by 11
the biggest problem for her Kelli Ward
is that last month a poll showed her
losing to Kristensen mo who is the
Democrat in the state of Arizona by 7
points so Republicans could lose another
Senate seat they lose one more Senate
seat and it's a 50/50 sentence okay and
Mike Pence becomes the tiebreaker and
it's unlikely that Republicans don't
lose at least one more Senate seat in
the upcoming election given the numbers
right now so figuring all of this you
would figure the mcsalley would be
running away but it's mixed Ally 31
Arpaio 29 Ward 25 so basically it's a
three-way dead heat did Republicans
learn nothing from Roy Moore did they
learn nothing from the Roy Moore debacle
this is one of my big problems with how
people perceive politics right now and
particularly with Arpaio less about Ward
who's actually a state legislator but
certainly with Arpaio
is that when you substitute attitude for
any level of political acumen or
knowledge when you substitute attitude
for policy you're gonna end up with some
of the worst people for the office
there's this weird feeling that's now
cropped up in the Republican Party it
was true for Trump maybe it'll work out
for Trump maybe it works out sometimes
it did not work out for Roy Moore it
certainly is not gonna work out for Joe
Arpaio and that is that populist style
is more important than your ability to
get the job done hey if my populist
style we mean that your non elite you
wouldn't want a non elite plumber you
wouldn't want a non elite basketball
player on your team I don't know why you
would want a non elite politician just
because it makes you feel like he's one
of us
hey he's one of us is less of an
important descriptor than it is a actual
counterproductive message to put forward
about your legislators so be a big
mistake I think for our pile especially
because Democrats are going to be
intransigent okay didn't let's get some
Democrats here so Democrats are saying
openly that they are not basically going
to negotiate here that all of this
yesterday was a fraud here is Chuck
Schumer he says listen we don't need a
border while we're not gonna do a border
while it's not happening to take away
the things that are needed to protect
the border for a symbolic and
ineffective political gesture there's
nothing to this but politics president
Trump is fighting for an empty seat
rather than smart policy that will
actually produce better security at our
borders okay so there Schumer saying
there won't be any negotiation mark
warner is saying that the Democrat from
West Virginia he says that the dreamers
are integral to our country and that we
therefore cannot even consider anything
except for a clean daca bill and read
for a long time we've said as part of
major immigration reform or even part of
giving this immediate relief to these
dreamers 97% of them by the way who are
either working in school or serving in
the military they're integral to our
country but that we would be open to
some level of enhanced border security
okay they're really not open at any
level of enhance border security they're
gonna hold Trump's feet to the fire and
force him to back down in March Pat
Buchanan said this yesterday I think
that is basically correct okay well I do
want to talk about Steve in being out of
Breitbart what that means in just a
second but for that you're gonna have to
go over to Daley wire , and subscribe
for just $9.99 a month you can get your
subscriptions to daily wire comm when
you do you get the rest of this show why
you get the rest of Michael Knowles's
show live the rest of Andrew Clavin
still alive you get to be part of our
mailbag you're gonna get discounts at
the soon to launch Shapiro store plus
you get to be part of the conversation
so Andrew Clavin next week On January
16th is going to be doing the
conversation this is the new thing that
we do we're Alicia Kraus basically reads
your questions to a to Andrew Klavan or
me or Michael moles next week it's
Clavin and you only get to have your
questions answered if you are a
subscriber all you have to do is go over
to the conversation page at Daley
wired.com after you subscribe and then
follow along type in your questions it's
gonna be January 16th 5:00 p.m. Eastern
2 p.m. Pacific and when you subscribe
again all you have to do is go over to
the daily wired Facebook the daily wired
Facebook page or YouTube channel to
watch but if you want to ask questions
go over to our page at the Daily wire
conversation page watch the live streams
start typing into the daily wired chat
box and drew will answer questions as
they come in for an entire hour again
it's January 16 5 p.m. 2 p.m. Pacific
join the conversation and that's Andrew
Clavin so you get to have drew answer
all of your lifelong questions if you
want all of those glories plus the famed
leftist cheers Hut or cold tumbler the
one that is often derided by fellow
hosts who are just jealous I mean let's
be
about this they're just jealous of the
glories of this thing you can get all of
that for 99 bucks a year so go check
that out right now or listen later
SoundCloud iTunes YouTube any of the any
of the podcast players we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so I do think that there is a little bit
of a danger here with regard to people
getting too excited about that meeting
yesterday with Trump not just because he
botched the policy but also because if
you're hoping that the media are going
to lay off of him because he had a
bipartisan meeting he got another thing
coming what they're gonna do is they're
gonna praise him for his bipartisanship
up till the point where he goes back to
the original policy he was espousing at
which point they're gonna rip him up and
you'll see this in this in this sort of
yeah in this sort of jab and jab and
punch pairing from from CNN so here's
Dana Bash on CNN praising Trump's
meeting yesterday at the White House
saying this is what we'd all hope that
trumps presidency could be I'm sure I'm
going to get hits this and I don't
really care I think that the bottom line
is that this is a year ago this is the
presidency that many people thought
Donald Trump was capable of we're not we
don't know if this is going to be a
results-driven debate but just the
notion of him being in command of him
wanting the cameras in there and wanting
the cameras to see him sitting at a
table with Democrats and Republicans
playing the role of a deal maker whether
it's its sees fruition or not this is
what people who had high hopes for the
Trump presidency
thought it would be meeting after
meeting like this okay so you can see
CNN is praising him look at that he's
just gonna be meeting with Democrats
it's gonna be great then Jim Acosta the
new chief CNN White House correspondent
whose only job is to yell at Sarah
Huckabee Sanders for a living he goes in
and he yells the terrible Huckabee
Sanders for a living forcing her to say
listen I'm not gonna negotiate with you
Jim I mean the media in other words
they're going to be Pro Trump so long as
they think he's making concessions to
Democrats the minute that he doesn't
it's over they may not be in favor of
this kind of deal those are in favor of
protecting American citizens and I think
we've hit a sad day in American history
but I don't believe that to be the case
because as we heard many of them say as
they said around that table when several
of you were in the room they are
committed to border security they do
want it and most of them have voted for
it previously before this legislation
hit the floor so anything different it's
just well they say thanks but no thanks
for a wall negotiate
with you I'm gonna let Congress take
care of that injury pingzhi the media
are already pushing Trump on this so for
all the talk about how Trump won a big
PR victory yesterday it is a it is a PR
victory it stands as the bleeding on the
he's crazy talk but when it comes down
to the policy discussion don't worry the
media will always be out to get
President Trump just as the courts are
there's a court ruling this one is
coming from a US district judge in San
Francisco barring the Trump
administration from ending daca okay
that's absurd that's absurd
it's an executive order of course Trump
can reverse an executive order it is
obviously legal for Trump to do that but
the district judge his name is William
Alsip was appointed by Bill Clinton and
of course he says that it is
unconstitutional for the Trump
administration to rescind at daca he
said the agency shall post reasonable
public notice it will resume receiving
daca renewal applications and prescribe
a process consistent with this order
they're a bunch of other courts that
have already ruled in favor of Trump on
this he says that else of justification
is that this is arbitrary and capricious
right he says that the federal
government can't just renege on all of
this but it's just it's just silly okay
the the judicial system is is now a tool
of the left in cases like this and it is
obvious that if a single federal judge
can halt an entire federal program based
on that that judge being terrible at his
job then we do have a constitutional
separation of powers question that must
be rectified I've always suggested that
judicial review is not a power that
should be given to federal district
court judges at the very least I mean
it's absurd that the presidents of the
United States enact a fully
constitutional policy and some judge
appointed by Bill Clinton says now you
know what we're gonna go no on that is
it that's sure nonsense okay in other
news Steve Bannon is out at Breitbart
news that is a very good thing if I've
not been clear in my feelings about
Steve Bannon then I would suggest it has
more to do with your lack of hearing
ability than my lack of clarity because
I've been extraordinarily clear that I
think Steve Bannon is a snake in the
grass that he is a leech I'm the ass of
power that Steve Bannon is a barnacle on
on the wail of others that he's never
built a thing in his life that he's
merely stood on the Foundation's built
by others to glorify himself Bannon was
finally fired yesterday
Rebecca Mercer apparently was the one
responsible for capping Bannon and
putting him out of work he will now be
occupying a cubicle at your local
Salvation Army where he can get those
clothes that he wears for free and he
can
and he can hang out with those who who
dress like he does in any case abandon
being out I love this story that he is
now going to be getting foreign funding
to lobby for trade with China or Lobby
on trade with China which should just be
really entertaining I'll be entertained
to see where Benin goes next it is a
good moment for Andrew Breitbart this
was not breitbart.com it was Bannen calm
the great tragedy and all this is that
Andrew Breitbart memory was smeared up
by Steve ban and turning this site into
something it was not I wanted to play a
clip of Andrew Breitbart so I've never
done this before because I really
hesitate to speak for dead friends I was
close friends with Andrew Breitbart
Andrew was one of the kindest and one of
the most garrulous people that I knew
there are a lot of people who met Andrew
and felt like they knew him really well
and that's because they did then the
thing about Andrew that was so unique as
a human being is that I knew Andrew from
the time I was 26 until he is Ari and so
from the 17 until the time he died in
2012 so until I was 28 years old so I
knew him for 11 years
really my entire adult life I knew
Andrew and I was friends with Andrew and
there are people who'd met Andrew once
who felt 90% as close to him as I did
and that's because Andrew was utterly
transparent about who he was he was just
as as outspoken and friendly and fun
with people he had just met as people
that he was friends with for years and
years I want to show you this clip of
Andrew from the Nixon Library this in
2011 about a year before he died talking
about what he saw as the rule for
Breitbart news like what exactly he he
thought Breitbart news was going to
become and the thing is is there get
there we're starting to learn to divorce
ourselves from the Democrat media
complex we still turn it on and every
now and then think that they're telling
us the truth as opposed to trying to
manipulate us and so we're gonna have to
start asking those questions and asking
the hard questions and I've seen a
candidate who was preordained as
electable go through three debates and
now he's sinking because he couldn't do
what everybody assumed that he could do
stop looking to the media to determine
what electable is okay so there's Andrew
and what he's really talking about there
with the Democrat media complex was this
idea that Democrats in the media were
combining to create narratives that they
were forcing on the American people and
what he saw Breitbart as was a way of
debunking those narratives instead
Bannen
turned it into a personal political
weapon against his enemies so he would
use it against enemies of Trump when he
felt that was in his interest he'd used
it against Jared Navarro when he thought
that was in his interest he used against
HR McMaster or he would use it against
Ted Cruz or he would use it against
anybody who he saw as impeding his
interests and then eventually he ended
up using it basically against Trump
himself
eventually he ended up you know speaking
to the media out of line out of turn and
going after the president's children and
then using Breitbart as sort of a funnel
for his viewpoint it's about time that
he was ousted it's a shame and a tragedy
that he was ever put in place I thought
that was a terrible idea to begin with
and the fact that that Bandhan lasted
there for so long is is a blot I only
hope that Breitbart news can go back to
its original vision there's a culture
centric media narrative fighting site
you know it'll be it'll be hard for them
I think to to go fully back to that
because the place has become so
ubiquitous Lee known as sort of a Trump
fan site that it's gonna be difficult
for them to back out of that and go back
to being a culture site but I think they
need to make that transition I think
that's something that Andrew would have
wanted Andrew never in a million years
would have hitched his wagon to one
candidate made that candidate his site
it just wouldn't have happened he
certainly wouldn't have turned his his
site into a campaign Oregon I sent this
back in March 2016 go back and listen to
my podcasts I talked about what Antrim
would have done in the middle of that
campaign I think Andrew probably would
have supported Trump in the end I think
Andrew and I probably would he disagreed
on that but I think that Andrew never
would have stood for his site becoming a
propaganda outlet or a bullhorn for his
own political aspirations or for any
particular candidate and sacrifice
whatever journalistic integrity remained
in order to do that I think that would
have been completely out of bounds so
I'm glad that Bannon is gone I think
it's good for the Trump administration I
think it's good for the country I think
that we can now have a real debate over
which candidates are good in which
candidates are bad outside of the
personal Darth Vader posturing of a guy
who legitimately never built a movement
in his life he just stood on top of the
corpses of other people's political
careers championing himself as their as
their legacy so good good riddance to
bad rubbish when it comes to Steve
Bennett okay time for some things I like
some things I hate and then we'll do a
brief Bible talk so things I like this
one is recommended by our own Mathis
clubber this is the movie moon with Sam
Rockwell I
watch it the other night with my wife it
is it's really well done I mean I think
that it was done then like a five
million dollar budget and it looks
really good I mean it's a very good
looking film the basic premise is that
Sam Rockwell is working for a
corporation and his job is to mine on
the moon and then it seems like he's
starting to go crazy and I can't really
tell you more than that without giving
away some of the the plot of the film
but it's a very good-looking film the
music is interesting I will say I think
it's a little bit over long I think the
runtime on moon is something like an
hour 40 so I think that it's the it's
now or 37 this this really should have
been more like a black mirror episode is
the truth it should have been more like
like a Twilight Zone episode if you've
done this movie in an hour 15 then it
would have just been fantastic it's
still a good movie it's not a fantastic
movie because it's at least 25 minutes
too long but it's Sam Rockwell gives a
tremendous performance I mean he's
really good in it
here's a little bit the trailer
[Music]
sambel reporting to central everything
running smoothly over and out
rock'n'roll god bless america
[Music]
good morning Sam do you want me to cut
Avengers lunar Industries remains the
number one provider of clean energy
worldwide due to the hard work people
like you three years is a long haul you
know two weeks ago Sam two weeks to go
buddy I think we got a live one I'm
gonna go out I'm gonna stop it there
because in the next five seconds of the
trailers a bit of a spoiler so it is it
is a movie that is that is worth the
watch it's a good creepy film okay other
things that I like so Trump did comment
yesterday an Oprah Winfrey's possible
candidacy this is the thing that I think
everybody likes about Trump is that the
guy certainly has no problem speaking
speaking out clearly on what he thinks
of himself and his qualities here he is
going after Oprah Winfrey yesterday
Calvino Oprah would be a lot of fun I
know her very well you know I did one of
her last show she had Donald Trump is
before politics her last week and she
had Donald Trump and my family was very
nice no I like Oprah I don't think she's
gonna love the gleamin is that when he
says this I mean if there's ever a
person who's never lacked for ego Donald
Trump is that person so yeah you gotta
love that a little bit okay time for a
couple of things that I hate so Chelsea
Manning should be in jail okay Chelsea
Manning is of course the transgender
woman who was a traitor to the United
States and Barack Obama freed Chelsea
Manning because Chelsea Manning was
transgender if Chelsea Manning had just
been any normal trader Chelsea Manning
would still be in prison but Chelsea
Manning on law enforcement Appreciation
Day tweeted out F the police disarmed
the police
hashtag we got this hashtag law
enforcement Appreciation Day and a lot
of emojis because Chelsea Manning is
legitimately a person with mental
illness and Chelsea Manning again the
fact that this person was freed by the
President of the United States to leave
prison and then slandered a law
enforcement officers who defend the
country as opposed to Chelsea Manning
who undermined the country is really
despicable okay other things that I hate
shannon sharpe there there's this this
tendency on
folks on the left to deliberately miss
read the Constitution of the United
States and the Declaration of
Independence because they are
historicists they will do a routine
where they suggest that the words in a
particular document are bound by the
actions of the men who wrote them so in
other words when it says all men are
created equal the people who wrote that
didn't believe that black people were
equal therefore all men are created
equal doesn't mean anything well no it
does mean something it means all men are
created equal and many of the founders
knew that that applied to slaves also
including people like Thomas Jefferson
by the way who essentially said as much
at the time even though he didn't act
properly in that way they here a Shannon
Sharpe from ESPN suggesting that the
Constitution was written for white men
and all this nonsense the Rob you
mentioned this this very country was
found on protest there was something
going on and British kept taxation
without representation freedom of
religion and all that other stuff
instead of saying they were out there
called founding fathers that's what
they're called they're not radicals they
look dr. King he was a radical uh-uh
Malcolm X he was a radical right Carla
capita he's a radical no no no no no no
because I think there should be justice
for everyone you shouldn't be treated
better than me because of the color your
skin you shouldn't get privileges all I
want all I want is fair and equal the
Constitution said it was gonna be fair
and equal now I know when you wrote that
you weren't writing it for me but you
said for the Constitution see it doesn't
say white man it says all men like well
they put that in there buddy
there was no blacks at the table there
were no women at the table so in
actuality they made all me all-white me
okay so the idea that they that they
wrote the Constitution only for white
men is obviously untrue we actually cut
a video on this that I think we're going
to be releasing in the near future about
why this is completely untrue if we
haven't released it already that the
Constitution was written for white men
it's just it's just nonsense the idea
that it was written for white men
ignores all of the Enlightenment
philosophy that predator that the
Constitution was was predicated upon and
the universal principles the
Constitution espouses just because you
are unable to meet your own standards
does not mean that the standards don't
exist the Constitution was not just
written for white people and there are
great black leaders like Martin Luther
King like Frederick Douglass like Booker
T Washington who would have agreed with
me not with Shannon Sharpe okay
final thing that I hate
final thing that I hate here I just have
to comment on this there's this pastor
and he announced at one of his services
I guess the name is Andy Savage he
announced that he had engaged in sexual
incidents with a 17 year old in 1998
when he was a college student working
with a Texas church he admitted this to
his congregation and said that he had
apologized and then the crowd gave him a
standing ovation here's what it look
like I'm sorry too Jules to her family
to my family to my church family both
then and now and most of all to the Lord
my repentance over the sin 20 years ago
was done believing that God's
forgiveness is greater than any sin and
I still believe that since then I have
tried to live my life in keeping with
that original act of repentance for any
painful memories or fresh wounds this is
created for anyone I'm sorry and I
humbly ask for your forgiveness I love
you all very much
okay that is completely inappropriate
you should not be given an ovation for
making a public confession okay the
purpose of doing repentance is not for
other people to forgive you unless you
received forgiveness from the person and
themselves and apparently this guy did
not get written forgiveness from the
girl apparently miss Woodson said quote
it's disgusting she told the New York
Times she said that that Savage forced
her to perform certain acts upon him and
he said that he thought that the matter
had been dealt with woodson said that
that was not true she'd not brought it
to law enforcement in any case there is
this tendency that we have where we'll
say well you know we'll forgive somebody
right we will forgive somebody you see
this with politicians all the time
Democrats well I forgive Al Franken and
you'll see people say oh I forgive
Donald Trump if you're on there if
they're on the right or I forgive right
more or if they if they committed an act
of repentance and we say well we forgive
them it is not up to you to forgive a
sin committed by somebody against
someone who is not you that's not your
job that's between that person and God
and the other person in Jewish
philosophy right before Yom Kippur
you're supposed to go around asking
everybody for forgiveness
the idea is that God is not really going
to forgive you unless you actually ask
the person that you have wronged for
forgiveness and you have to ask them for
forgiveness at least three times before
God has any say in the matter
just from a religious perspective the
idea of giving somebody a standing
ovation for confessing a sin in front of
an entire congregation and sin against
another human being that I I just I find
that disreputable I find it disreputable
and I don't think religious people
should be cheering anybody who committed
a sin against another human being and
then confessed it in front of a third
party you're the third party you do not
have the capacity to do this okay it's
one of my it's one of my pet peeves
actually that there are people who will
say things like well why don't the Jews
just forgive the Nazis for the Holocaust
right with if they were just a little
more forgiving it's not your job to
forgive okay it's not your job to
forgive you can say that you think it's
good that this guy repented I think it's
good that he repented too but it's not
my job to say that he's off the hook
because he certainly isn't that giving
him a standing ovation is I think really
kind of a negative nasty thing for a
religious community to be seen as doing
so I actually can't believe it I forgot
to get to the Obama Presidential Library
because the design is incredible so we
will lead off with that tomorrow I
promise unless there's some other piece
of huge breaking news but we will get to
it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis pleather executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Alex and Garo audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing